donc nous allons essayer de rester le
plus prudent possible la seule chose que
nous faisons c'est le témoigner avec le
direct avec les images etienne r daniel
wolfromm le scénario de ces dernières
heures
pékin reste place de l'université 1h14
du matin l'armée tirent sur la foule qui
manifestent il y a des morts et des
blessés ce sont les toutes premières
images d'affrontements roumanie reçu
depuis une semaine
9h30 de la sp annonce que pour la
deuxième fois en 24 heures la foule
converge vers le centre ville
malgré la répression 9h59 lagence
soviétique tu as décrit des scènes de
fraternisation entre des soldats et les
manifestants
les gens ont découpé le sigle du parti
communiste roumain imprimer depuis 40
ans au centre du drapeau national 11
heures les premières rumeurs sur une
fuite de chaouchi ce coup ci recule
devant l'immeuble de la télévision
on annonce le suicide du ministre de la
défense va s'il est niché à 11 ans 29
s'est confirmé l'armée se retire la
place de la république et tout le centre
de bucarest sont noires de monde
11h43 les studios de la télévision
roumaine sont envahis dans le même temps
on annonce la création d'un front du
salut de la patrie dirigé par un groupe
d'intellectuels d'artistes et d'ouvriers
ordre est alors donnée d'arrêter
ceausescu sa femme et son fils qui sont
en fuite
11h58 un bulletin de la sp annonce que
les frontières de la roumanie sont
ouvertes
les premiers journalistes étrangers
bloqués depuis une semaine peuvent enfin
rentrer dans le pays dont 15
début de l'après midi à bucarest
l'euphorie gagne tout le peuple romain
juchés sur les chars la foule est en
liesse dans le centre de la capitale
depuis la terrasse où hier encore
nicolae ceauscescu s'adressait à la
foule en tentant vainement de lui vanter
les mérites du communisme les
manifestants jettent par terre
maintenant les symboles de la dictature
pendant ce temps à la télévision
roumaine que nous avons retransmise et
traduite toute la journée sur l'a5 et en
direct les responsables de la télévision
montrent les victimes de la répression
de ces derniers jours par là et toujours
mobilisés en fin d'après-midi avec
insistance les responsables du
soulèvement précise que rien n'est fini
et que des troupes fidèles à ceausescu
peuvent toujours menacé le retour
fragile à la démocratie